[Music]
all right there's a lot there and we are
going to get everybody's thoughts on it
there's some commentary during the time
um but
i'm he spoke for about
26 minutes
he packed a lot in there he had a lot of
i would say divisive
statements and then at the end said
there's nothing we can't do if we don't
do it together so there's unity i guess
at the end um so much to talk about um
jesse you were the one who was silent
during the thing and now i'm dying to
know what you're thinking he's an angry
man he's a bitter man he's humiliated by
the afghanistan situation he's upset
with the economic recovery where it
should be but it's not so he's taking
that anger out on the unvaxed he's
targeting 80 million americans who don't
trust him don't trust the media for good
reason countries been lied to for three
decades why would you trust a politician
or the media telling you anything and
instead of uniting the country
against this pandemic and against china
because that's where it came from he's
trying to divide the country against
itself for political exploitation
you know who people trust they trust
their doctor so instead of doing all
this crap that means nothing give the
doctors the shots have the doctors in
private practice shelve the shots they
can stick these things in people's arms
you can get rid of all that other
mistrust when you do that one thing he's
obviously pull tested mandates never
said mandates it's requirements now
that's the new word to look out the
federal government mandate's very
interesting so there's about two million
federal government employees let's just
say 70 percent are vast so that's a half
a million that aren't facts he's going
to fire a half a million government
employees for not getting the shot
if he does that he's the greatest
bureaucratic reducer i would call him a
conservative
he gets rid of half a million federal
employees wow jobs get filled yeah that
would be a big deal the other thing if
you have more than 100 workers at your
company you got to jump through all this
red tape they're going to fire people to
get to 99. you don't do that during a
labor shortage and it's just going to
create a lot of turmoil in the in the in
the economy he was also speaking to
these vaccine extremists
you know these people that have the two
shots they can't wait for their booster
they wear a body condom when they leave
the house
still living like it's
spring 2020 in deep quarantined afraid
to go to the grocery store he's telling
them i'm on your side right it's these
nasty unvaxed masses these are the
people that are hurting us and then he
says if the economy doesn't recover
strongly enough it's their fault
he's already set up an excuse that if
this thing doesn't work out it's
therefore he goes we've done our part
federal government quote unquote and
then he lied and said governors
are discouraging vaccinations that's a
bald-faced lie not a single governor has
said that and basically declared war on
abbott and desantis so you guys better
be ready he's coming for you this is his
mission accomplished moment cleanup when
he said we were free from this in july
now he's backpedaling and if he gets
away with this power grab he's going to
be bloodthirsty imagine what he thinks
he'll get away with next all right uh
great thoughts i'm glad we came to you
uh greg one of the things he said is he
said many of us are frustrated with the
80 million who aren't vaccinated
you do hear that no you hear that from
the media you don't have people they're
interviewing
please what do you think my question was
this is that speech going to persuade
any of those it doesn't persuade anybody
no the great unifier is saying that all
those are vast are mad at those that
aren't so this is not true it's all
there to just gin up more animosity and
cause division basically he said the
unvacs are the new terrorists that's
what he did like he showed more anger
towards that 80 million this amorphous
80 million that he actually won't
specify
what constitutes the 80 million which is
kind of interesting but he showed more
anger towards them than the orderly and
kind taliban right the very business
like he also lied he lied so much and he
was basically this whole thing was he
was blowing his own horn because he blew
it in afghanistan this was his way to
show that maybe he is competent so he
had to gin up the fear it was a
interesting little game of saying
everything's great but it could just
totally go to hell in a minute and it
wouldn't be my fault and it wouldn't be
my fault it's these other people's
faults and then he's comparing the past
uh with uh you know like before he got
there to now people have to remember
this is a guy
that said don't trust the vaccines
that's the guy the same guy who said
that is now saying people who say that
are public are publicly dangerous or in
or endangering public health uh and uh
it's uh or blocking public health was
the word that he used um he talked he
talked a lot a bit
i think the thing that bugs me most
about it is that
he found an easy target
and it's a target that the media likes
to punch it's a punching down thing but
he won't say who they are right and i
don't trust anyone especially him who
says you know the only way to get back
to normal is to do x but they keep
changing x because
on how it affects them politically so
his government said we're not doing mass
mandates as much as like like three
weeks ago i'm sorry vaccine mandates
that changed and now he has basically
created unlimited power he has unlimited
power he can have private businesses
fire employees
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else